je vous présente vacui marktrock je vous
présente prometheus
donc voici cyrus n'a diffusé ces
personnels ne peut pas transporter
d'humains encore mais ça reste qu'il ya
beaucoup de ressemblances avec les
fusées de ranaz heures pour fabriquer
subsiste un développement qui dure une
année complète donc on rentre en
septembre on accueilli vous puis on
lance le projet puis à partir de là on
va faire des estimations sur papier
alors faire des simulations président
ensuite tous condamnés on vend des
revues des angles ont cliqué votre
joindre on va discuter des améliorations
à faire caisse doit fonctionner ou pas
puis la fabrication commence vraiment
janvier donc de janvier à juin jusqu'à
la compétition va travailler à fabriquer
des fusées qui par la finition
[Musique]
m
malgré un vol qui a été majoritairement
un succès comme vous pouvez le voir ici
on a subi des dommages
c'est à dire que après quelques secondes
à l'image le moteur eu une défaillance
il ya un bris de la chambre de
combustion
et puis qui opposait à la perte
la section du bas de la fusée
[Musique]
c'est un moteur qui pour difficile à
développer qu'ils n'ont plus de temps de
développement d'investissement
nous on a eu la chance d'avoir une
équipe très forte cette année et dans
les années précédentes pour servir à
vous
[Musique]
or not en général on fait des fusées
sens il existe un marché pour ce genre
de fusées là typiquement qui vont aller
à quelques centaines de kilomètres
d'altitude et donné 10 15 minutes
d'apesanteur pour déployer des charges
scientifique
je dirais que ça serait une introduction
pour ensuite passer à un autre niveau et
aller dans les filets de plus haut
calibre
ce qui m'intéresserait beaucoup de
futurs des choses géniales chronos tic
ça nous permet de développer des
compétences applicable à brive puis
c'est vraiment une capable d'une
possibilité de former le leader élie la
main d'oeuvre de domaine dans le domaine
aérospatial et oui avec lui
[Applaudissements]